foreign
Pages as they arrive in the next half
hour we'll see what's making the
headlines with journalist and author
Christina Patterson and the evening
standards defense editor Robert Fox
so let's see what's on some of those
front pages for you now the constantly
changing and developing situation in
Russia leads many of the papers tonight
the Sunday Telegraph says the Wagner
group forces threatening Moscow have
turned back after striking a deal with
Vladimir Putin not to spill any Russian
blood but says the Sunday Times the
whole incident has left Vladimir Putin
humiliated
this is the front of the Sunday Express
Russia on the brink
similar headline in the Sunday Mirror
who sin pushed to Brink
the star says the Russian president has
vanished from Moscow and pictures Wagner
group leader Evgeni pruzgovin with the
headline Putin the boot in
other people also pictures both men with
the headline Dogs of War
we're reminded that by scanning the QR
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us and we are joined tonight by
journalist and author Christina
Patterson and the evening standards
defense editor Robert Fox welcome to
both of you let's um start with the
Sunday Times if we could
um first up and their headline Putin
humiliated by Mutiny uh Robert would you
agree with with that headline is that
the case has President Putin been
humiliated by this Rebellion although
now quashed it seems
we'll um come to that later about what
what has happened to Putin himself uh
but I think that it is the first time
particularly during the special military
operation the war in Ukraine since
February last year were his strategy has
been shown and importantly shown to
Russians in Moscow and in the cities of
the West Roscoe Petersburg
um that it it isn't what it says it is
and it is not working and I think that's
the piece that pagosian has got across
and that's the piece that he now owns
the papers have of course found it very
difficult to keep up with the news and
there are developments happening all the
time but the Sunday Times and the Sunday
Telegraph are pretty good very good
quotes from the Sunday Telegraph uh
about what Mr pregosian thought he was
doing I'm not a mutineer I'm a I I'm a
patriot I want to support this country I
want to get rid of he doesn't quite use
the word scumbags but he said I want to
get rid of all those people in charge
who are very corrupt
uh and Christina you've um obviously had
a look at the the article as well they
are focusing I mean the headline is
about um Putin being humiliated do you
think that is the underlying fact from
this Rebellion that we have seen today
there are lots of underlying facts uh
not least of which it is that Russia is
clearly in the hand of in the hand of
Warlords now uh because priyajin has
shown himself to be in some ways as
powerful as Putin and uh the fact that
Putin has essentially uh bowed his
demands we don't know exactly what they
were obviously some kind of face-saving
formula has been reached and the
ostensible details are that priyajin can
go and a pregosian sorry can go and live
in Belarus I'm sure he's been dying to
go and live in Belarus and that he will
no longer face 20 years in jail or
whatever it was he was facing this
morning but and of course Putin
absolutely has been humiliated this is
as Robert just said the first time that
he has been exposed in quite this way
I'm sure there's increasing suspicion
across Russia about his strategy but we
have to remember that most people get
their news through him if you any any
dissent is punished with imprisonment or
worse and so you know the vast majority
of Russians will be swallowing the party
line and actually have no choice but to
do that unless they want to risk their
lives but Russia is all about strong men
this whole thing alarmingly is all about
strong men and by strong we mean people
with armies behind them and who do not
care what happens to the young men they
use as cannon fodder the reports we get
of the brutality that both that
certainly that Russian soldiers inflict
on ukrainians but also the 18 year old
Russian boys who've been sent away from
home for the first time essentially just
being slaughtered just fed into Putin's
meat grinder for this crazed crazed
Enterprise to restore some kind of
fantasy that has been washing around in
his head that hasn't really been
articulated did the whole thing is
tragic and I think today there's been a
kind of Temptation to think my enemies
enemy is my friend you know oh isn't
this exciting pets Putin will be
humiliated perhaps he'll Stand Down
perhaps he'll even leave but it's
extremely unlike you that this is going
to lead to you know a happy ending for
anyone this is more lawlessness more
violence and what looks like now is it a
precaution and Putin are a kind of
united front about to feed yet more
people into the Ukrainian War so I very
much doubt that this is going to be good
news for Ukraine a direct quote from
pregosian today saying we got to with
200 kilometers of Moscow in 24 hours
without spilling a drop of the blood of
our Fighters now the moment has come
when blood could be shed Robert do you
believe that this is the the real reason
why that march to Moscow was stopped
that he didn't want to to lose any
troops
I think we're overthinking this I was
talking to a friend who is very
experienced in Russia and Russia and um
Hinterlands and she's been talking to
her friends via uh a covered uh a means
uh versions of telegram and so on and
she said it's worse than what you can
think she's half Italian and she was
saying Italians like seeing plots and
everything the plot the point is this
was not by Karl Marx this was a Marx
Brothers plot that actually pagosian it
now seems didn't really know that
clearly what he was doing from one
minute to the next why it began is that
I think he knew he and his troops
so-called were in trouble they were
being slaughtered massively on the
backwood front and they had to get out
now you come to the point about the deal
which is extremely interesting there is
a deal and we only know bits of it and
what he demanded of course was the head
of Defense defense minister shoigu and
the head of the operation and the
commander-in-chief the chief of Defense
staff gerasimov were fired we don't know
where that's got
and Putin having
gone on television immediately and said
this is a stab in the back it's terrible
this must be dealt with this man's a
terrible traitor now he's now saying
he's not quite quite a traitor after all
and he's going off because I've done a
deal with uh lukashenko in Belarus at
that very dodgy indeed because I tell
you a lot of people in Belarus don't
want 25
000 uh Wagner thugs because a lot of
them are convicts with very very serious
records behind them exactly as we've
been hearing it is chaos violence and
it's in a spiral and we don't quite know
the direction of that spiral yet and
Christina we read in the Sunday
Telegraph that a key element of the the
deal that was struck um via lukashenko
was that the Kremlin would drop plans to
abolish the the Vaga military the Wagner
military group
yes um I mean
yeah I think what's been interesting
here is that
um precaution has has done quite well on
telegram but presenting himself as kind
of some some more moral figure sort of
um disapproving of the way that Russian
troops are being sacrificed in this war
he is the guy who went in and uh went
into prisons last September and said oh
well you know you can be let out of
prison if you join my Army and then
promptly you know enormous numbers of
those people went straight to their
deaths you know he's not a nice guy and
um I think the reason he's been
protesting because as Robert said huge
numbers of his uh soldiers have been
slaughtered and haven't been given it
you know they they're not getting the
the weapons and protection they need
um and there were you know we don't know
the exact politics between Putin and him
and why there were uh plans to
disband Wagner but you know these guys
want one thing they want Power that's
what they want and they will do
literally anything to get it and that's
why this thing is so terrifying because
they don't care who dies who suffers or
what price anyone pays for their own
personal power and whatever deal has
been brokered it's because for the
moment they obviously feel it's enough
to buy them another day and carry on
with trying to either maintain or muster
more power in Putin's case obviously
he's desperate hold on to it and
precaution himself has Ambitions of his
own which go well beyond being head of
the Wagner Brew we don't know exactly
what they are but you know I wouldn't be
at all surprised if he was eyeing
Putin's job so it's all pretty
terrifying Robert the the mirrors
headline is that Putin pushed to the
brink um what what do you think now
happens to the man who who pushed him to
the brink we know that he's uh being uh
well I don't know if you described it as
forcibly moved or relocated to Belarus
but that's where he's moving to but what
do you think actually happens to him now
I think progression actually will last
for quite a bit because he's an oligarch
he's a particularly tough rough and
unscrupulous in other words gangster or
oligarch remember how this started and
this started only a week ago in this
thing in this phase when uh pagosian of
very widespread social media denounced
the operation in Ukraine
has got up by oligarchs to stuff their
pockets that that's why they wanted to
take over Kiev now these kinds of things
it's a drip feed that people do begin to
have access to social media and they are
affected by it because there is
something very strange in putinism that
has happened this time
no crowds have turned out to support him
and usually the regime can whip up huge
crowds to come out and say yeah our
beautiful president he can go on forever
and by the way if we're talking about
the future of uh uh of Putin he's due to
be up for election and we know it's all
a beauty parade and nonsense by and
large these presidential elections fixed
in the first instance the thing about a
beauty contest uh like this uh uh of
these kind of show elections you've got
to look beautiful and Putin doesn't look
at all beautiful and not very successful
and that's the real Blow from this we
have seen him in setback mode in a way
that his people hadn't really before
since he first became president in the
early noughties and this suggestion by
the male Christina that the leader of
the Wagner group pregosian was offered a
huge bribe by Vladimir Putin to um call
off
his assault or the March towards Moscow
yeah this is fascinating I don't it says
that um a British officials or defense
officials believe that he was offered
um Millions so I mean I wonder where
they are I'm sure they're not just you
know speculating but it would certainly
explain the sudden backing down and it
was extremely unlikely that the offer of
going to beautiful
in self would itself would be enough to
deter him from what he seemed determined
to do before
so it sounds plausible but it if that's
the case then it absolutely underlines
Putin's weakness because if he really
has to throw money at people now to stop
them marching on Moscow with their 25
000 conscripts
um then that is you know a sign of
extraordinary weakness so yes
fascinating story Robert what what do
you think is it likely that it's all
about the money
it's possible but it's not all about the
money I mean a few millions in a large
sum
would probably be chicken feed to
pagosian pregosian is in charge of a
private military company which is a
euphemism for uh a high-tech
band that indulges in brigandage I mean
they've taken over gold mines in Mali
they've got hold of rare Earth elements
mines they know where to go they're
incredibly potentially wealthy and
actually wealthy in in parts but they
dare to go where others won't place that
they've gone into
Sudan they've been in Somalia and I
think that's part of the game of what of
what pagosian was doing he wanted to
keep this core group of thugs together
and that's why he would willingly have
taken a bag of very very dodgy rubles in
order to transport them out of the
country
into Belarus now apart from the whole
Belarus thing is is fascinating because
I think it's extremely fragile and we
know lukashenko isn't very strong and
now Putin absolutely owes him but what
progression is saying that Ukraine war
I've had it you can take me out of it
and that is quite a vote because the
Russian soldiery there will take that on
board because a lot of the really dirty
nasty terrible fighting which shouldn't
gone on it was just made no sense from
both sides as long as it did in Batman
was being done by the Wagner group I
think in terms of the deal and what is
really going on and who is saying what
to whom we've only heard a smidgen of it
because part of the demand was that
Gardner gets pay conditions and
integrated with the Russian Armed Forces
but didn't want their command and they
wanted the head of them sacked and we
want to know where General grassimov and
Mr shoigu is and by the way in the last
uh 30 hours shoigu hasn't been seen
that's the defense minister indeed I
wonder if we can cross to to Christina
just to get your thoughts
in terms of um the the wider conflict in
Ukraine and what this means now
I see you're flashing up the story about
the tech experts is that the one you
want me to talk about Jillian
no we're talking about the um
sorry in terms of The Wider conflict I I
really honestly think we just don't know
I think obviously Ukraine will want to
say this this shows how weak Putin is
and you know and how if you only give us
more weapons we will win and I wish it
was as simple as that it certainly does
show that that Putin is is weaker than
as we said then then he has thus allowed
himself to appear but I'm afraid I don't
think it has any very clear implications
for Ukraine if as Robert suggests and I
hadn't thought of that if a pressure
accompan that's it now
again
say again I've been talking about him
all day and I've now completely
if he does if he does get out of there
and go after his other more lucrative
interests clearly that would have a
different make a difference because he's
got 25 000 troops he'd be taking away
from the battle but okay um it's been a
distraction for the ukrainians
eventually we must leave it there